la parole est à Monsieur Thierry kzic
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues lors du
dernier projet de loi de finance le
gouvernement a décidé de manière
unilatérale et contre laave de toutes
les associations de collectivités
territoriales de supprimer la CVAE une
fois de plus après chaque suppression de
recette fiscale locale vous nous avez S
dans cet hémicycle la main sur le cœur
que la perte de cet impôt serait
compensée à l'euro prêt les promesses
n'engagent que ceux qui y croit et
l'Association des maires de France et
des présidents d'intercommunalité la MF
s'est insurgé contre le fait que dans
certaines collectivités le montant de la
compensation théorique est nettement
inférieur à celui de la CVAE qui aurait
été perçu en 2023 force de constater que
l'engagement de compenser à l'euro prè
la CVAE n'est pas tenu je rappelle que
cette année ce sont près de 650 millions
d'euros qui manquent à l'appel alors
face à cette problématique il vous faut
trouver des marges de manœuvre
budgétaire et il semblerait qu'à l'heure
du réchauffement climatique vous en ayez
trouvé une très surprenante comme vous
le savez il a été institué dans la
dernière loi de finance pour 2023 un
fond vert ayant pour objectif
d'accompagner les collectivités
territoriales dans la lutte contre la
crise climatique et contre
l'effondrement de la biodiversité
pourtant sur les 2 milliards d'euros
alloués au dispositif en 2023 530 sont
prévus pour compenser la suppression de
la cveae la circulaire du 14 décembre
2022 relative au déploiement du fond
d'accélération de la transition
écologique dans les territoires demande
au préfet de s'assurer que les
collectivités concernées par la
suppression de la CVAE bénéficient du
fond à minima à hauteur de la
compensation prévue or s'il était
convenu que les collectivités
bénéficieraient d'un accès favorisé au
fond vert afin de retrouver une
compensation intégrale de la CVAE
intégrer de cette manière la
compensation avec le le fond vert et de
nature à rendre plus difficile l'accès
au fond en lui-même pour les
collectivités bénéficiant de la
compensation